fan de rodez bonsoir bonsoir alors une
peu une première réaction peut-être anne
hidalgo donc en tête avec une estimation
à 30% des voix suivi de rachida dati
puis d'agnès busan avec 17,6 pour cent
elle d'avoir une réaction à ces
premières estimations stéphane rozès
chaque quart une finale est évidemment
un k 5 et jamais le pad des hanches ou
qu'on n'avait autant us mais est donc là
effectivement sur paris nous sommes
prêts à cette situation assez paradoxale
à 60 % des parisiens ne souhaitait pas
la réfection d'anne hidalgo mais elle a
pu profiter de deux phénomènes le
premier c'est au fond une opposition
très c'est entre les républicains avec
rachida dati d'une part et d'autre part
un conte la république en marche des
parties fils et puisque les candidats
d'un candidature griveaux ne faisait pas
l'unanimité il cédric gasnier s'est
présenté en distance et puis il ya des
écologistes en avant à l'hidalgo est en
position d'être en dépit d'un mauvais
qu'il en résulte autant que rachida dati
n'a pas faire la paire 6 annoncée
peut-être parce que la participation en
baisse
la peña tissier parce que son électorat
était plus un électorat de parisiens âge
ils sont inquiets du corona coeur du si
des risques de propagation dans notre
présent et c'est un facteur que l'on va
longuement commenté merci pour cette
analyse
en tout cas anne hidalgo effectivement
dépasse largement ce qui avait été
annoncé dans les sondages elle était
créditée de 24% à cheetah dati
elle était à 26% on le voit il ya il ya
un écart ce soir et par le jeu des
alliances finalement qu'est-ce qu'on
peut envisager pour un second tour si
tant est qu'il y à un second tour selon
vous eh bien ils payent hop je préfère
pouvoir à partir de ce soir au fond de
l'inconnu essentiellement c'est que va
faire cédric tille des skis tu vas cette
neige blizzard world d'al koud donc
cédric villani et pour partie un faiseur
de roi mais à d'alco est quand même dans
une bonne situation parce qu'elle risque
de bénéficier
tu auras d'yves mans là où c'est
possible de la liste de d'expédia
retrouve écologie les verts qui avec 11%
fait un score peut-être un tout peu
décevant pour eux parce que sa campagne
avait été à cycle épique peut-être un
mot ses fans en rosace sur le score de
daniel busan souvient elle avait été
envoyée à la mairie de paris après ce
qu'on a appelé l'affairé griveaux 17,6
pour cent
l'estimation qu'est ce que vous en place
est bon c'était une tâche un peu un peu
pour elle en amour de reprendre
prodromes campagne de pages un griot qui
sur le fond et de la forme avec la fin
que l'on connaît avait été quand même
assez assez désastreuse donc au fond
elle aura des les dégâts tout temps que
quand même à gaza à renoncer à sa
fonction de ministre de la santé au
moment de l'émergence de la crise
coronavirus et donc elles risquaient de
subir au fond les formes d'étonnement
qui a déplu aux nachi sous ce poste elle
a été néanmoins favorite et par le fait
que son successeur
assemblée je dirais faire correctement
son travail au banc dans l'opinion
publique nationale et parisienne le
corps aux navires us deux tenaient un
vrai sujet de préoccupation le même
corps navire vie ce qui entraîne ils
savent être sens à la principale besson
des municipales oms très importante de
l'abstention de 7 points puisque la
participation est dorénavant à 46% alors
qu'elle était à 63 cents dernières
municipales et donc là il ya donc le
problème c'est que on peut considérer
que la qualité des résultats ont été
altérés justement par abstention ce
n'est pas une abstention de nature
politique
c'est une abstention penance de citoyens
ayant craint pour leur santé lors du
godet deuxième problème
deuxième interrogation d'exécutif âtre
raison d'or de matija ces municipales et
de ne pas les remporter
quand même qu'une augmentation de
l'abstention de 17 points semble donner
tort à l'exécutif a fortiori tu fais tu
picornavirus le deuxième tour devait
être reporté à plus tard
donc on fonce et son ca que vont retenir
les français su que la photographie pedn
ce premier tour des municipales est à la
fois altérée par forte housse de
l'abstention pour des raisons sanitaires
et d'autre part à philadephie utilité
des futures mères alors on le sait et
sinon
pas la fonction de maire et que ceux des
chenaux l'énergie si tu laisses tu me
coupe une confiance d'une majorité de
nos concitoyens
néanmoins une prime aux sortants 1 c'est
le cas souvent pour ces élections
municipales est-ce qu'il faut maintenir
les maires qui ont été élus au premier
tour est-ce qu'il faut maintenir ses
résultats et finalement recommencer
selon vous pour un poil pour les autres
ça semble difficile on va voir ce que le
conseil de défense qui va être élu et ce
qu'on s'oriente comme certains le
pensent faire un confinement total testé
en début de semaine prochaine et a
constamment total on voit pas comment y
effectivement il y aurait par report du
second tour mais on voit pas non plus
que des maires et but est le premier
tour comme par exemple gérald darmanin
et d'autres bien sûr mes fils pilar
compte est ne soit pas ne soit pas acté
leur élection ne soit pas appelé mais on
sent bien que au total ça n'est pas sept
se sont par ce que montre la triste est
isation du vote au premier tour
la cristallisation du poteau 2e tour au
fond de mode de scrutin à deux tours
c'est une sorte de rite électoral qui
est un tout petit peu comme une mélodie
musicale
on ne peut pas impunément de cassis
dynamique entre la dynamique de premier
tour et la dynamique de deuxième tour
donc tout seul au fond très
insatisfaisant et âmes aide à revenir
sur ce qui a été sans doute une erreur
une préhension coeur on pouvait pas
demander aux français à la fois d'avoir
des comportements de retrait face à la
pandémie du coronavirus est à la fois
c'est une exception dans ce rite
électorale pied
pourtant dans notre pays que son ipad
merci beaucoup stéphane rozès d'avoir
répondu à nos questions sur rt france